I welcome to this video a bit late I had
screwed up the window but some reason it
was far too slow not quite sure why okay
playing emoji are from the US had played
him quite a number of times recently and
oh I've got a 100-percent scoring and
subscribe if you don't see that too
often seven out of seven ok Joey for all
the same ish sure let's see black hair
black now has a choice it can play with
the bishop a 60 at Bishop be 70 92 I
could have tried to play with Ned f3
here mmm because of his somewhat
somewhat uncommon in order ok now we I
just have the the normal theoretical
position here 98 so the may move he
doesn't play it and allows the pin
that's a very dangerous thing to do ok
for attending he five
yeah add very similar game recently
where black also allowed all this Quincy
7s what was played in the other game
maybe this the exact position if not
it'sit's very close Castle so now it
basically has to play g5 which does not
look too attractive yeah okay so Bishop
g3 to tech here now probably not I want
night g3 the question is should i go to
e 1 or 2 f2 let's go here to have the f
file open yeah of course he can he can
now take upon yeah but the compensation
is quite quite obvious with black having
his King side completely weakened I
didn't want to take on c4 as a somewhat
accelerates the night to a 2d six takes
Knight x 9 36 and maybe he needs to take
on d3 at some point okay just knight at
5-4 yeah come on that's not let's not
waste any time it's probably the best
move oh wow
okay taking five and let's see how to
increase the pressure I could I'd like
to double the blonde on the FL like rook
a2f too but they discovered that don't
want to take and give the night the
opportunity to go to the six the other
interesting move of course is is to play
is to play each form hmm yep okay let's
do this this preparations it's a good
multifunctional move anyway I'd really
like him to take come on take it he
doesn't hmm
this
and relief to a form
I could play Knight each know he's got
25 okay I thought night here
plane to slowly here I mean it's it's
it's it the problem is what I'm doing is
I'm spending too much time it's a
position that is probably good for white
in many ways and I just take too much
time to look for the best the best line
yeah this is probably not the best
possible way where I keep keep attacking
and this is really enough yeah it needs
to most annoyed it then I just take
epsilon I think
John right there for me fatigue 94 yeah
my default Bishop takes and a player
will get 5 at the end it wow I didn't
think that I could afford that one okay
maybe with rook evade maybe ruka fate is
still playable yeah but you must play
that otherwise I'm going to establish a
look on at five with too busy for or or
maybe if I've got a meeting at a queen
g4 at five years this is the big threat
so he probably needs to play rogue evade
then probably i'll just drop back to a
five I don't see a direct win no I don't
see a direct money
I really don't get why not okay maybe I
maybe maybe you can play that one but it
looks a bit strange to give me total
control of the FR now that's that that's
too much that simply too much I thank
hmm
seeing a direct wind okay let's just
improve the position Queenie and AJ I've
combined ideas a good eye open entering
Winky six okay Queen enters on gtx check
time morning so let's check how this
isn't my check Queen yet mate checkmate
Queenie wait yeah that was I think too
much blue too much pressure on blacks
position I probably didn't play it in
the best possible way but around here I
don't believe that blacks position is
really really good yeah yeah around here
you could really ever think or try to
try to find better whoops this is
certainly a possibility but that's
better better there's something better
than what I played
you look the computer as always giving
me a big advantage so it probably was
was okay at least keeping some edge yeah
and this this is computer season mate
mate in seven that's cool obviously I i
didn't i didn't find it Queen f3
estimating and six moves now queen of
three okay this is just plus five queena
three again wins and now look f6 because
of mate ah ah this is stupid really I
could have played just this one after
the game you always see it quickly check
check Angie's feet checkmate yeah this
is quite easy to see actually that's
okay yeah twin f3 again yeah I made the
conscious decision just to go for four
small or let's say that as the steady
edge without any any big risk and well I
managed that but in the process I could
have one far quicker okay but this is
really enough to to win yeah allowing
Bishop g5 in this was too much check
allowing Bishop g5 in that way it's just
a very risky thing to do okay thanks for
watching